[Music]
in porn star for president news
anything's better than Trump at this
moment submitted by tissues folio issues
that's actually good a porn star has
announced that she will be running for
president in 2020 that's dope this is a
porn star run to be mayor you know the
governor California governor yeah in
2003 yeah a porn star named Mary Carey
ran for governor California um
but yeah so this point sir though her
name is Cherie de Ville do not know who
she is I don't what's going on Disney
[ __ ]
classic [ __ ] it yeah so this is what she
look like
well she's covered up doesn't count this
is Cherie and so she's saying that she's
gonna be running for president in 2020
you guys will never guess who she picked
for her VP oh no this guy he's just
completely random so her vice president
pick is Coolio dress I think Coolio
should be running for president yeah why
because he's just more popular this porn
star I think the porn star might be more
popularly I don't I thought I watched a
lot of porn but I'm not too familiar
with her I have to do this nothing the
laughs is so hard that even mama thinks
that my mind is gone but I ain't never
crossed a man who didn't deserve it he
was pretty like a foot yeah there you go
what was the movie that majors - that's
what it was
we live in the kingdom every day exactly
we were doing we were younger to in the
shower she throws up the left side for
no reason your heart is the [ __ ] rub
your body down with the Westside
especially with my fifth lots of sauce
of [ __ ] in the chef you know who else
wears flip-flops socks
Vanessa Wow yeah are you trying to tell
me so that makes it better cuz she's
just as weird
she's like your little sister that is
like looks up to you and dresses like
you and little [ __ ] she's so weird
what's the other song that was before
that though he had a cooler like I
forgot what it was the Fantastic Voyage
yeah Oh
Fantastic Voyage there you go become
this porn star wants to run for
president
so trump inspired her actually oh so
she's she was saying like before Trump
was elected you know I always thought
like a Republicans Democrats like one of
them will get it like political people
but then now that Trump won with zero
political experience she's like shitty
he could do it anyone can do it
sometimes yeah yeah but he's still a
business tycoon yeah you know he's not
just like this average [ __ ] Joe she
should have used Arnold Schwarzenegger
as an example yeah it made more sense
she's a bit of a stretch there I mean I
want to show you guys a video of her
press conference that she had announcing
her her run for presidency it's like you
peel sketch yeah everything it seems
like it was and then towards the end of
the video they were like you guys might
be asking is this real this is real I'm
gonna be running I'm gonna be filing all
the paperwork is that so this is real
but it comes off like like a fake movie
it's called [ __ ] awesome calm yeah
[ __ ] I can't I can't okay let's
continue because she wants to make
America [ __ ] awesome again y'all okay
miss Sheree
deville
and I promise you I will not make
America great again
no we will make America [ __ ] awesome
again there's like five people clapping
really and I'm proud to announce that I
am running for president of the United
States of America but she's so serious
I'm already in the process of putting
together a team of like-minded people
so other porn stars you to a man that
changed my life I'm proud to call him a
friend
Coolio honestly something that I thought
would never happen but in life as in
politics anything oh I thought that was
reindeer things for [ __ ] Christmas
little reindeer things coming out of
this I can't even believe this is real
life I know it's just like the movie
idiocracy every year it's gonna get
crazier and crazier next a wrestler is
gonna become president dude but you
can't like look up president of the
United States and there's coming your
[ __ ]
you know it'll be like that's the first
light you put up her name and they just
heard with a [ __ ] shot in the face like
that's so embarrassing for the country
or is it
I mean first lady who's done some pretty
raunchy [ __ ] in the past nobody wears
ones like more of a Playboy magazine it
was very artistic you know so I give it
that but I'm talking by this little
public in facebook but what's more
American than porn though like that's
one of you know that's I don't know if
we invented it but it's pretty American
hmm we just gotta [ __ ] wear it like
that's that's us man yeah you know what
that's interesting though that you you
find porn very American but yet we're
still so scared of nudity and like in
Europe they're not
it's interesting I know huh that's the
American Way though you invent things
that you're scared of
so you embed like the biggest [ __ ]
juiciest fattest burger in the world and
then you tell everyone you're gonna get
diabetes we have like the baddest guns
in the world and then we have like okay
you can't know don't you I mean out that
stage you can really have so I didn't
know that from the diabetes you can do
some rounds yeah because you lose uh
what is it the feeling like one tiny
little scratch and you don't feel it and
then you can end up getting gangrene on
that thing you feel check that's [ __ ]
I saw also I was watching this [ __ ]
right and this lady was like I had two
diabetes and I was taking a shower all I
heard was a crunch and my toes were gone
whoa like I just felt like I crunched
off her toast crunch soggy she just
awful lot like a piece of fried chicken
like Douw like got like three of her
toes just crunched off which which type
of diabetes is self may is it type type
1 or type 2 name is type 2 okay and in
the type 1 is your like born with it
yeah I think so yeah I had I had these
classmates in my fourth-grade class
there were these twins that had diabetis
and then um they're always jealous with
them I was always jealous because they
were able to eat snacks throughout the
class Oh cuz of their pleasure so I want
to diabetis because I was like that's
not that I could say I had diabetis I
wanted a baby and if my dad was
diagnosed with diabetes like oh I don't
know when I was in fourth or fifth grade
and I was like and all these people
would have diabetics I want diabetics
these are so [ __ ] stupid because like
one girl I dated she used to make her
teeth crooked on purpose because she
wanted braces that was I didn't do my
teeth crooked but I want a braces so bad
I kind of got that one
you know like with your wiggle BTW
wheres my handicaps I didn't see it as
handicaps I'm like these kids get to
[ __ ] pick their frames they get a get
the color that they want like it's so
cool like that
I didn't really need glasses I started
wedding all the time and I [ __ ] myself
what would you do that you find glasses
- were just randomly they don't so like
I need them a little bit and so the
optometrist is like just wear it in the
classroom when you need it but then it
was just so clear that I liked it all
the time so I just kept it on all the
[ __ ] time and then you still get
worse and worse and worse and worse and
worse [ __ ] already okay we don't know
the science behind things we just make
assumptions yeah no I did that with my
eyes eyes like an idiot I stared at Sun
knows a little cousin wanted glasses
like dark glasses stupid I think I was
like in the second or third grade and
I'm like classes are so cool and then
everyone tell me like my parents and so
big don't ever look and directly into
the Sun it's really bad for you and I'd
be like I just do that [ __ ] to me sneeze
all right the photo reflex I'm mrs.
Smith yeah that was pretty cool
well I always wanted a cast so people
could [ __ ] sign ever got it
well guy never broke a bone really I
know did you try no I never tried to
break up all yeah but this porn star for
president though imagine she actually
gets elected like this how crazy [ __ ]
in America was getting to the point
where like all these people are getting
famous off of things that we would have
never imagined they would be famous for
like just five years ago ten years ago
and now we have Trump it's all so hard
though cuz you do need like a billion
dollars to even campaign well she says
she's gonna be doing it like grassroots
style like really small and she's gonna
be running as a Democrat but she's gonna
be like to fund her campaign she's just
gonna be doing it little by little
question so no one's gonna even know
she's running yeah basically did you
need billion dollars pretty much what
she's saying like her her porn career
like she's so popular and porn that if
you've seen porn you've seen her oh
where the [ __ ] was I I never seen you
maybe I'm not in that category she's a
jenna jameson
yeah help you know jenna jameson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]